hello in a very warm welcome to the ftth
council event here in Munich I'm talking
to Hardwick taba Hardwick it's the first
morning there's lots of people down
there you must be delighted indeed I'm
very delighted about seeing how big this
conference got this year it is the
biggest fiber-to-the-home conference
ever the registration already yesterday
exceeded 3300 delegates which makes it
really the biggest event and we have
other all-time high number like for
example we have ninety one of our
members exhibit in here at the
conference and showing the newest
product and solutions so it's really a
busy and big conference another it's the
official morning this morning you did
have some pre-show workshop yesterday
that's correct already yesterday we had
nine workshops running in parallel with
more than 800 participants and these
workshops were about topics like how to
develop the German market what are the
newest technology solutions on fibre and
also how to set up the business case for
a fiber network and so what can people
expect to get out of the next two days
the next two days will be packed with a
lot of topics about the setting up and
accelerating of fiber networks this
includes the financing of fiber networks
so how to get financed in place for a
fiber network the other thing is the
positive impact of fiber networks on
productivity and economic development
here we have some real interesting
studies showing this positive effect and
then of course we also present how fiber
will enhance or enable new application
and services for the end users and for
work and for this specific thing we also
have a dedicated exhibition area the
world of application where the people
not only hear about it but also they can
experience multi-screen TV a health
applications or even working from home
like you are in the office so everything
is shown here and people can experience
it yes so we really saying that people
are already benefited from FTTH
technology today
this is true we have the newest market
data which will also be presented during
the do days here at the conference in
Munich and the good news is also in
Europe there is a steady increase of
fiber users still the increase is not as
fast as we would like to see it and I
can already say the increase in Germany
is even a bit slow so that's one of the
reasons why we said we need to go for
Germany to give it a push and to
accelerate 50 deployments in Europe and
in Germany in 2012 so how I guess I mean
we're seeing we've got record attendance
we've got record number of exhibitors
you must be really excited yes I'm
excited and I'm really looking forward
to these two days at the conference here
in Munich thanks for talking to us
you're welcome to secular ftth connects
the world when are you getting connected
ladies and gentlemen welcome to Munich
for the ninth edition of the ftth
conference creating a brighter future